はじめしゃちょー始める柴田
リーで富山県民
支持率調査してほしいですよそれ
ありこんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
すいません
ちょっとあの3億円のうちに関する新情報ですニューにここでも起きたかと
この家でもついに起きたか
と同じことは
繰り返されるんだと
なんでこうなんか嫌なことってしたくなるのかな
って思うようなことが
また起きてしまいました動画のサムネにもタイトルにもある通りですね
3億円のお家に
ですね
あのこちらが突然届きまして
もうやだから隠すね
もう本当に嫌だからちょっと
隠させてもらっていいタイトルにもある通りですね
家にですね引っ越してから20日なのまた
いたずらが始まりましたあの
私のお家の住所にですね
代引き引き換えで物が届きました
はいこちらの中に入ってるんですけども
一応中は見させてもらったんですけども
すぐ戻しちゃってもあの
嫌ではないんですけどそれはいたずらだわ
みたいな内容のものが入っててなんでそんなことするんですかねっていう
銃声に思ってしまいました
佐賀県の豪邸ですね結構
静岡の中で有名な建物であの
普通に家の前とか通る
でかすぎて目に入るんすよ絶対どんだけ
住所隠しても目に入っちゃうしばれる
しもちろん
外で撮影してる僕も悪いんですけどもあとすごいのが
この家なんか有名というか
すごい建築物的にもすごいらしくて
なんかその家の雑誌とかお家の雑誌とかにも
ここ掲載されててそもそも隠す気もないし
核戦でとも思ってないしなんかじわじわ
広がるんだったらもう堂々
しようと思って近隣のお家の方々にご挨拶して
僕みたいなものが住んでしまうんですけども
今後ともよろしくお願いしますと
あの
しっかりとご理解を得て
今ここに住んでいるんですけれども
それにもかかわらず
またやってくれたな
代引きで物が届き始めました
さすがに
もう
収まったからと思ってもう大丈夫だろうと思ってたんですけどもやっぱりこういういたずらはどこに引っ越しても起きるんだなと思いましたで代引き換えが2件来て1個がですね
2万円ぐらいだったかな
2万円のものだったんですけども
郵便屋さんに聞いたら中身
ちょっとだけ見せてもらって冷蔵庫だったら
小型のあの会社で代引きで絶対物を頼まないようにしてるからもう
冷蔵庫欲しかったですけども
これ多分違うな
絶対うちじゃないし
高いから冷蔵庫はちょっと
絶対頼んでないです
と思って受け取り拒否したんですけども
問題
こっちです
これですね
1590円代
引き換え
1590円だったんで
あそれぐらいの金額だったらまあ
受け取ったんですけども
中身見ていこうと思いますこちらです
わかります女性ものの下着です
バカにしとるやろ完全にいたずら
これはもうあの小さい冷蔵庫100個いつ
ってダメですけどダメですけど100歩譲って
なんか使い道あるからいや
だめなんですけども分かってます
ただなんか一瞬でも自分頼んだからってよ
ぎっちゃったけどもう女性用の下着に関しても隠し
案でしょこれずるいよねこれこれ
送り主の名前も書いてないしいや
これはやっぱ郵便の方からすると
俺が頼んでるかわかんないと思うんすよ
もう告白ならマジでもう俺本名
も出てるからエナはじめ様って書いといたら俺が頼む
みたいになっちゃうんすよ極悪ですよ
女性もの下着なんか
袋田さんなんかすごい簡易的な感じだからさ
あの中古使い
[音楽]
人の家に送ってはいけません
これも当たり前ですから
よくないっすよ今回は本当になんか
久々に起きたしなんか
1個だけたら全然良かったんですけど
まとめて2件来たから
まあなんかいたずらがまた流行ってくるのかな
と思ってあのちょっと動画にさせていただいております
なんか
僕の前のお家に住んでた時もやっぱどうしても住所場でしちゃっててその時は
炎上してたからなんかもうやりたい放題で肥料になる分とか送られてきたんですけども
まああの時もあれはダメですし今回も
代引きで人の家に勝手に物送って行けない
これ当然です
そしてこれははっきり言わせてください
代引きではじめしゃちょーの家に物を送っても断固
受け取りませんもうこれが例外です
これを久々すぎて
序盤で取ったんですけども今後一切代引き
で始め社長の家に物を送ってもてか
代引きじゃなくても基本的に知らない人からのものは受け取りませんので
やめていただけると僕もだし大地君
管理人もだし配達の人とか郵便局も結局
受け取り拒否になると
戻さなきゃいけないのでいろんな人に迷惑がかかるので本当にやめてもらえると嬉しいです
てかやめてくださいどうすんねんこれ
まああの今回
自腹で引き取ってしまったのでありがたく使わせていただきますが
あの今後こういうことは本当に
そういう活動してる人で
分かりやすい家に住んでる人も仕方ないのかな
と思って今一度注意喚起させていただきました
長崎
僕んちょう
うろついてるあの親御さんとかお子さんたちもよく見かけます
動画にはしてないけどでこういういたずらも増えてきたので
僕というか僕の周りに住んでいる方達のためにも集めていただけると
とても嬉しいです以上の
[音楽]
怒られないよね怒られないよね
自分で払ったものだから人のじゃないし
自分のだし自由に使っていいんですと